I saw this tweet this morning and it
just gave me my first laugh of the day
we always need one of those it's a
photograph of Al Davis shaking hands
with Darth Vader and the story that came
with it from the post of the person who
posted it I needed to hear in person
long time front office executive with
the Oakland Raiders now chairman of big
three with Q one of our favorite guests
a me Trask Iran the Rich Eisen show how
are you aiming I'm doing well how are
you rich
I love that that that photograph and
that post please the floor is yours
well thank you and it was quite a moment
we had entered into a sponsorship
agreement for that game on it was 2004
and we'd entered into it was a night
game and we had everyone there Darth
Vader was there the stormtroopers were
there I mean everybody was there as part
of this sponsorship so pregame elves on
the field he's watching warmups
and the executives that are part of this
sponsorship deal are there and they're
stars evader so I walked up to out on
the sidelines I was a few feet away from
him and I interrupted him and he's
watching not only our team won't warm up
but he loved to watch the visiting warm
up and do a little scouting and I
interrupted him which you know as you
know he loved that and I said I need you
to say hi to Darth Vader and he looks at
me I mean though I I just smile ear to
ear when I remember the expression on
his face I said no look it's part of a
sponsorship we've entered in the
agreement I really need you to do this I
need you to come say hi to Darth Vader
and I can't say on air because I don't
want to get you in trouble his precise
response but it was who the blank and
blank line would let's say truck Vader
and I sort of had to explain oh don't
worry about it sponsorship movie r2d2
sir what just come say hello come say
hello and we did it and he was gracious
and that picture was just quite a moment
it sort of captures it right yeah
because well there's so many questions
he really did not know who Darth Vader
is in 2004 I understand he's a football
guy but any weed is that for real he did
not know you know it was certainly
struck me as absolutely positively
sincere now you know people have
responded in the
on twitter saying well you know is all
he focused on was football and well that
was his primary focus he was a student
of the world I mean he studied world
events and he there was music that he
loved and used to sing to me actually as
I was leaving his office and and he
really didn't like pop culture and some
regards but I think he didn't know who
look let me just put it this way rich I
took as quite sincere his statement who
the blank is Darth Vader so I introduced
them tell me he sang my way Amy tell me
that's the song he sang oh yes oh no he
did he absolutely did and I shared
stories in the book I wrote rich to us
that sometimes when he and I would be
arguing about something and I'd be
leaving his office he would sing the
refrain from I'll do it my way and I
remember turning and looking at him
saying yes I know Amy I love these
stories so well you didn't think about
maybe maybe the image of Darth Vader or
now it would be you should give him the
Luke Skywalker or r2d2 who showed up
that never crossed your mind you know it
was a moment and the executives that had
entered the sponsorship agreement with
us were there and there's Darth Vader
and you know they're talking to me about
you know we'd love to meet al and I'm
just like all right I'm gonna grab out
he's gonna meet Darth I really didn't
give it thought from a Star Wars
character standpoint I gave it thought
from I knew the figure on that
sponsorship agreement and I wanted to
make sure that we were entirely an
absolutely gracious to our sponsors and
if darth wanted to meet out with them al
was gonna meet Darth
in the black hole fan I'm a little bit
I'm a little bit embarrassed that I
never ever thought of something until
today when someone tweeted it to me why
did I not go to that game with my hair
like Princess Leia with the bottom what
is the answer Amy I don't have a good
answer rich I missed an opportunity to
do Princess Leia here mmm-hmm
you know what Amy maybe for maybe for
the next big three venture maybe you
should do that coming up this summer
we've been we've enjoyed some time with
you
you imagine the look on ice-cubes face
if I show up to a game and sit right
down next to him dressed with my hair
like Princess Leia a me on behalf of
every but please do that just give it a
look give it a whirl I'll see how it
goes see how I'll let you know
Amy great chatting with you take care of
Amy tres may the fourth be with her
the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience